our show wants to be a place where we
can come together and build genuine
relationships have
real conversations and lift one another
up
so when i saw our next guest creating an
initiative doing
just that i knew we had to chat with her
take a look
hi my name is lovey ajayi jones and i am
a writer a speaker or podcast host
and i'm also one of the four women who
created the share the mic now campaign
shout out to my fellow creators and
founders rosema saint john
glennon doyle and stacey bended as we
searched to figure out what allyship
looked like
we decided to ask prominent white women
that we are in community with
to hand over their instagram accounts
for a day to black women who typically
might not have
that major platform because when the
world listens to women
it listens to white women and it is time
for black women's voices to be given
space
over the course of a week we had 50
black women agree to take over the
accounts
of 50 white women and tell their stories
amplify their
voices talk about their lives and their
experiences
because we wanted to show what community
could look like and sisterhood
in action our hope would share the mic
now was to catalyze the change that only
happens when we truly listen to each
other's voices
and now ladies and gentlemen lovey ajaya
jones
lovie now can you share
with me this was such an exciting
question for me to just get right in
how did you select the women you chose
to
start this initiative with yeah when we
decided to do share the mic
now we were like we want to pick women
who have already used their voices in
some way to speak up about racial
justice you know they're the people
who've already said black lives matter
so mean bose got with glennon and said
let's do this
in this big way glennon said okay i'll
be back i'll go talk to some white women
who i respect
and see if they'll say yes and glennon
went and said hey i just need you to
hand over your instagram account for a
day to a black woman who's
amazing are you damn and everyone said
yes without question
yeah she would come back and be like
hillary clinton just said yes brene
brown just said yes
jen hatmaker just said yes and for us
once we had
the white women who were prominent
confirmed we went
to black women who we whose voices we
really loved and whose voices needed
bigger platforms to be heard how did you
um
pair the women because i thought that
process to me was really interesting as
well
so we actually called the zoom and had
everyone join us i'm thinking assistants
were going to join us but when i'm
seeing yabba blade join when i'm seeing
tarana burke
and i'm seeing ashley judd all without
makeup and seven o'clock in the morning
i'm like this is special and we decided
to pair people up based on
industry who we thought were easily
matched like gwyneth paltrow and latham
thomas
or chemistry like esther perel and
yvette noel shore
so we created those pairs and just hoped
that magic would happen
and magic did happen because some of
these pairs are now collaborative
like they've worked together they're
continuing to talk they have actually
built
friendship with each other and actually
we're going to share the mic
today together who are we collaborating
with today levy
so i think someone amazing is rachel
rogers she is a mom of four
she's a wife she's just an overall dope
woman
and her company hello seven empowers
entrepreneurial women to become
millionaires without losing their sanity
and she's somebody who is worth
us sharing the mic now with please
welcome rachel rogers
oh hi rachel thank you so much for
coming on the show
thank you so much for having me tell us
about your business hello seven rachel
so what i do is i work with women
entrepreneurs and what i saw is so much
conversation
in the women's entrepreneur market about
getting to six figures getting to 100k
and i'm like
i don't know if y'all been at 100k but
it's not enough money you know
i'm like no why are we setting our goals
so low
let's go for a million let's build seven
figure businesses
and so i just started talking about it
and i started teaching it because i
really
saw that a lot of the training out there
just got you to six figures but it
didn't teach you how to get to seven
figures and how to build a million
dollar business there was like
no advanced training that was focused on
women and so i decided to create that so
that's what we do at hello seven and
it's a lot of fun we
really enjoy it we live in a society
that talks about you can have it all
the the mantra out there i think makes
us feel like
it is all on our shoulders absolutely i
listen i make it very clear i'm not
trying to be all things for my children
for my husband even for my business it's
crazy how
even breadwinning women are always the
ones doing the the
bulk of the domestic work and so for me
i'm like listen i want to be there to
parent my
children but i don't need to do their
laundry
and clean for them and cook for them and
do everything for them
so i make them part of a conversation
and i trust that they can handle that
and understand that
i am so honored to share the mic with
you
today rachel lovey i would love to ask
you
can this be a place that we can continue
and foster
this incredible initiative that you have
launched
and been a game changer for i would love
that i think
your platform and who you represent in
this world is significant and
you've been able to share the mic now
with women who typically don't have this
platform
is part of the action that we can take
to change the world
i am honored and humbled to do so and
all i can say is
let's do this
you